[Music]
hey folks
welcome to the dark horse podcast live
stream our 69th
dr heather heing how goes it it goes
pretty well
well you know it's it's going reasonably
well a little hectic this week as you
know but
uh you know it's um it's all happening
we're still here let's put it that way
we are still here
those of you who are watching are
apparently still here or at least you're
still there wherever there may be
interesting yes no i think that's uh i
think you nailed it
it's uh fully described true and
uninteresting
true possibly uninteresting yes
so um today we're going to talk about
power
race and social media right we're going
to talk about better or worse
covered mortality and pre-existing
conditions a little bit uh
we're going to review a truly sexist
obituary and what we should do about it
yes um and uh review a new finding in
octopi
or octopodes or octopuses they're all
apparently legitimate pluralizations of
octopus
as luck would have it i was speaking
with eric about um
octopi yesterday and he prefers
octopoids
which i think is legitimate i that is
not one of the ones that i ran into as i
was looking for the proper
pluralization i'm sure there are many
many many but the three that i just said
are the most usual pluralizations of
octopus let us agree to drive
everyone crazy with octopuses
which is it's one of the legitimate
pluralizations i know but it drives
everyone crazy because everybody feels
sophisticated saying octopi i think
i'm going to go with octopods octopodes
all right
cool so first though um if you are
interested
in more q a after the q a that follows
today's live stream we are having
our monthly two hour private q a that
you can access through my patreon
heather haying
tomorrow at 11am pacific and
uh and next week you will have your
patreon conversations
um and there was maybe one more
announcement before we
launch into today uh let's see
there's at least one more announcement
one is we will be giving away
another um clubhouse invite
to anyone who wants it they will be
immediately useful to somebody who's got
an iphone apparently it doesn't work on
ipad which strikes me as odd but
nonetheless
um android is uh the clubhouse app
i have heard different you have heard
different all right well
i know nothing about this except that i
have heard from people who are using
ipads that it's working okay interesting
i looked it up the other
day and i could find no evidence of that
but i hope it does work on ipads but in
any case even if you have an android
phone
uh you're welcome to uh enter our
drawing for this by entering the hashtag
clubhouse in the chat and then
a winner will be selected at the end of
the broadcast
um was that the other announcement yep
all right so then we've uh we've done it
all right let's um i wanted to start out
with you're giving me that look i'm just
laughing
but you're not thinking about divorce no
okay
good all right then i'm i'm cool with it
i can i can handle the look
um so all right let's uh start out with
a little consideration
of power and i must tell you that i'm
thinking about this
um because of an event that took place
yesterday on clubhouse and before you
all change the channel those of you who
don't want to hear about clubhouse
as i predicted some people would right
and i get it i get it but
here's what i want to tell you before
you yeah you click away
right if somebody was to start talking
to you
about face mash in 2003
you could well have the correct reaction
i want no part of hearing about this
that sounds awful
and it's not something i'm interested in
on the other hand if you
fast forward to 2021 and you realize
that face smash
becomes facebook and for better or worse
starts altering the way the world
understands itself
then being in on that discussion early
on hold on
was it really called face mash yes okay
that's that's one point of order uh
second is
just because the thing became important
doesn't mean that everything that
happens on it in its early instantiation
is important
also what about my place or whatever
myspace was called before
i have no idea what any of these things
were called and obviously most of them
are disappeared
so so you know i mean you and i this is
actually one of the one of the places
that you and i differed the most that i
am i
i hold myself intentionally at arm's
length from almost all of the new stuff
in order to retain my ability to think
clearly and do creative work over in
this space
like i just don't want that polluting my
head so i am i am not buying into the
like
obviously you need to pay attention to
anything you heard about face mash
seriously face smash yeah i think so i
think so um
i'm not saying anything like so many
things that matter
the vast bulk of what takes place there
and even one of the strengths of the
platform is the ephemeral nature of what
takes place there we're talking about
face mesh now no
we are now talking about clubhouse
but my point is clubhouse doesn't know
what it is yet even the people who've
programmed it don't really know what
it's going to end up being
at the moment it appears to be crashing
into podcast world
right we have all sorts of people coming
through we hit last week
um bill gates was on sam harris was on
uh earlier we had joe rogan um
elon musk has been there and all of
these things have played out very
differently i would say
bill gates uh told us nothing we didn't
already know from bill gates on the
other hand
elon musk interacted as you might
imagine as somebody who is a denizen of
the
new online world right he actually
participated
with people so anyway something is
happening there and it's figuring out
what it is
and my point is even if your your
understanding is that this is just a bad
development which it may well be it's a
development that is going to have a
profound
impact on your life even if it's not
clubhouse now it happens that facebook
and twitter are now competing directly
with clubhouse
clubhouse having discovered that there
is apparently a hunger for conversations
that are somewhere between twitter space
and podcast space and so there's this
jockeying for position and my point is
even if it's all bad right what it is
going to be
is unfolding and you know it's very hard
to move
twitter or facebook now right they're
too powerful they're too big
but in the early days the community that
was there had influence so
again i don't want to be in the position
of defending this this may be
the next level of derangement of
civilization that's coming
but at the moment it's happening in real
time it's changing
i i think both are likely could well be
could well be in any case um the
event so let me just set the stage for
those who have not
paid any attention to what clubhouse is
zach do you want to put up that
screenshot i sent you okay so this is
not
the uh room in which things went insane
yesterday this is a room that is
actually i think currently on clubhouse
contains some good people uh some people
i know must say oh there is somebody
well familiar you see a nice uh
mixed group of people men women racially
mixed
um in any case these guys i don't know
what's going on in this room but
these people are running some sort of an
experiment about how to affect room
dynamics
right um okay so
yesterday what took place so what you
see on the screen
you said like since i have not been on
it i don't think you have said
that it's voice only and then it's
ephemeral i mean maybe you said it was
ephemeral
i'm about to explain it so there are
rooms
the rooms that you see to go into are
rooms that
involve people that you follow there is
a wrinkle
that there's the ability to block people
and i think
if anybody on the stage has blocked you
you don't even see that a room is
available
and inside the room there are two
there are really three but for our
purposes there are two levels there's a
stage
anybody on the stage can talk at any
time that they want
people in the audience cannot talk in
general people in the audience
can click the button in the lower right
hand corner and ask to come on the stage
and the moderators have discretion over
whether or not to bring them up
so that's the dynamic what happened
yesterday
is that michael tracy the journalist
started a room
in when the title was approximately um
is clubhouse too obsessed with wokism or
something like that
in any case uh i went into this room
quite late i think the discussion was
well underway michael tracy
was i believe um having difficulty
moderating the room a
person came onto the stage to speak
and challenged the fact that there were
by her accounting no people of color
with moderator privileges michael tracy
made her
a moderator i did not see that
interaction but that's what i've been
told and then a coup took place
and everybody in the room acknowledged
by the end of this discussion that it
was a coup so
the person who had been given moderator
privileges first
kicked michael tracy out of the off the
stage
then kicked all white people off the
stage and the conversation radically
shifted
and it you know so it was a takeover now
at one level who cares about some
takeover in some ephemeral
room on clubhouse on the other hand
the nature of clubhouse is a discussion
and what took place in that room was
stunning not just to me
but to many people including peter
bogosian who was in the audience
and benjamin boyce now i would just
point out that
peter bugosian benjamin boyce and myself
are three very
well versed people when it comes to
discussions
of wokeness racial interactions
right it would be hard to impress us and
yet all three of us were impressed with
what took place in this room it was
shocking impressed in a negative way
tremendously negative and my suspicion
is that
most people have not heard a
conversation like
this one and so in any case
the um the nature of the
i think probably peter and benjamin and
i are going to have to
discuss what took place there in order
that people can get any real deep sense
of what it was
but what was uh just fascinating
was the fact that although in general
there is a wide diversity of opinions in
any clubhouse conversation above a few
people
the diversity of opinion dropped to
zero and what happened was increasingly
outlandish things were asserted
on the stage with no objection from
anybody
which spoke to what i'm going to claim
is a kind of
power and one of the obvious results of
this
will be that anyone who is on clubhouse
and paying attention to it
and who knows what you just described
a moderator who is chastised
uh who is asked to add someone else
based on a demographic
may well not do so in the future and so
legitimate inquiries about increasing
diversity that might be legitimate
although we can put aside for the moment
whether or not um
seeking diversity across demographic
features is going to maximize
conversation quality but that this is
likely to cause
exactly the opposite thing this is going
to
quite literally silo people um more
because
uh future conversations um by moderators
uh who have created a group around them
of people who you know because it's who
they know
look somewhat like them in some regard
um if a woman says you need more women
you need a woman on the stage or a black
person says you need a black person on
the stage
those moderators now have legitimate
reason to be concerned that what is
happening is not good faith but it's
actually a coup attempt
so perfect you've just described the
birth of a kafka trap
right you're now damned if you do and
damned if you don't um
and so that of course is a very
dangerous dynamic
right right um one certainly wants and
in fact in general people have been
uh pretty generous with uh moderator
privileges and in general the rooms are
pretty well
served by having a fair number of people
from different perspectives have those
privileges but obviously if anybody can
kick anyone
off the stage and you know i mean so the
idea is that any moderator has
as complete a set of privileges as any
other moderator regardless of whether or
not you set up the room or
just you know just added exactly um and
so
this then goes to imminently gamble so
gameable
and um so i wanted to think i wanted to
think out loud a little bit
on the question of what is power because
what i saw
yesterday take place over i mean i was
in the room for
i don't know three plus hours um what i
saw took place was a clear demonstration
of power and in fact the very first
thing that took place
in the immediate aftermath of this coup
i i think i
short changed the story just a little
bit was
that a bunch of people on the stage and
it's very hard to tell when many people
are trying to speak at once who is
speaking
it is relatively easy to tell when one
person is speaking at a time and rooms
differ as to whether or not
people talk over each other or wait
their turn but in this case
many people appeared to raise their
voice
and try to prevent this
ushering of people off the stage they
wanted a
room in which there was room to disagree
all of those people were eliminated
so what you had was inside of
i don't know maybe it was 30 seconds you
had a stage
that was diverse become
at least uh at a racial level
become segregated so segregation
happened in this room
almost instantly and well but and you
know frankly more importantly at an
ideological level
exactly that's the thing is not only was
it racially segregated but it was
limited to those people who
were apparently and this became apparent
over
you know the course of hours were
apparently willing to sign on
to anything offered by anyone in the
room including
completely preposterous ideas i mean if
john mcorder or coleman hughes or thomas
chad and williams or chloe valderrie or
you know any number of
other uh you know smart black people had
shown up and said i'd like to come up on
the stage i don't think they would have
been welcomed
by by by your account of what it sounds
like was happening right
in fact uh john mcwhirter was
misportrayed
on the stage he was portrayed as a
conservative not surprising
but he was portrayed that way i was
brought up somebody noticed me in the
audience i was
brought up um basically to be
cross-examined you mean brought up to
the stage or you mentioned
okay i was brought up to the stage and i
was asked if i was a white supremacist
i was asked again
it's almost the four-year anniversary
why not play this game again well but
this is this is exactly it and so
uh whatever else we can say about this
environment
at one level this was a lot like the
ability
of somebody imagine a virtual i i'm not
a fan of virtual reality i'm very
frightened about what it's going to do
to people's cognition
over time but imagine virtual reality
that would allow you
to teleport into the evergreen riots
with no physical
safety issue but the ability to be first
person
in that situation how much would that do
for people's understanding of whether
this was or wasn't an important event
whether it was or wasn't being
misrepresented right
that ability to just be present is
very persuasive and so
i i have the sense frankly that people
generally people on both the woke and
the anti-woke side
would have their viewpoint altered by
you know the ability to participate in
this conversation even just to sit in
the audience and hear it taking place in
front of them
would i think convince a great many
people that something important was
going on and many people i expect even
on the woke side would have the sense of
actually
i don't want any part of that right
because all of those claims are
i don't want to say all although frankly
virtually every claim
that was made was uh extraordinary okay
so what's to be done then
um yeah so this thing was ephemeral uh
and um you saw it firsthand it's
hardly the first time you've seen this
firsthand and so did benjamin boyce not
his first
time at the rodeo either peter pagosian
same thing you know
um and i presume i know less about
michael tracy but i
believe that he knows uh enough about
this to have
recognized at least in retrospect what
was happening um so
you know you were not further informed
um there you you think there would be
value
in people um in other people who did not
choose to be there
in hearing or reading um
this this thing that was ephemeral what
what then you know what does it mean or
what value can be derived from it
all right so uh for one thing
um let's just say peter was actually
tweeting about this
this morning about this conversation and
his point was the
constant refrain in this discussion or
at least the recurrent refrain was that
it all must be burned down
that this is effectively that
civilization oh civilization must be
burned
civilization is effectively white and
that whiteness
taints it beyond repair and it must be
burned down
now my point is for the vast majority of
people who have
had it right who have had it and may be
marching with blm
the discovery that there is at least a
a contingent wielding substantial power
whose viewpoint is actually our purpose
is to burn this down
and then things will be better because
they can't be worse
right that discovery the discovery that
a great many people who call themselves
abolitionists whether
they are talking about prisons or the
police or
generally both right that abolitionists
have taken that honorable term
and basically turned it on its head and
are
think it's clever to uninvent
civilization and that imagine that
somehow that will improve things
that that would be a wake-up call that
would actually allow us it would be the
gateway to the actual conversation
that we need to be having and so this
brings me back to the question of power
so
loosely speaking i would say power is
the ability
to reallocate or redirect limited
resources right whether that is people's
time
whether it is their attention whether it
is money right
whether it is access to
a coveted spot in a school in a
uh an organization whatever it is the
ability to reallocate a limited resource
is power now my point is power
tremendous power is being wielded
by a movement that is composed of people
who actually have positions that cannot
be reconciled with each other
the burn it all down people are a
substantial contingent
but there are lots of people who would
not burn it down and know better than to
burn it down
who are wielding power together with
them and my point is
those two need to see each other right
and those of us
on the outside need to understand
actually
that the movement is these two
unreconcilable things and that means
that we potentially have partners
inside that movement who we can reach if
they will stop
signing on to this reflexive reaction
well i mean i think this is consistent
with
um what we've been talking about since
the protests began last
may and june and what jeremy lee quinn
in your two conversations
um with him that are on this channel um
talked about as well that that he
learned by going
to many of the protests and i think some
of the riots and then also to
the the protests that turn into a riot
um at the capitol on january 6th by
you know a totally different group of
people um that really with regard to the
people on the so-called left
um it's not one one thing it's not one
organization
and earl you know we in fact we see we
saw some people who
um identified themselves as part of
black lives matter saying what the hell
is going on with the anarchists
and antifa and you know the anarchists
some of them will say oh we're not
antifa and vice versa and black lives
matter not and like what is trans black
lives matter doing in with the rest of
this
and you know what where did wall of moms
come from and you know
there's so many different moving parts i
think it's actually
um it's a it's a good way in perhaps to
say it's not one thing it's two but it's
not two
it's it's many many many and um
many of the people who are just kind of
fence sitters which is a majority of the
of the silent people right now who are
you know think they're good liberals and
therefore have to agree to this stuff
um aren't sure what all they believe
and also the martin bailey is being
played all the time and so they'll hear
something about all white people are
racist and go really
okay i didn't know that's like well you
know probably not you or you know
whatever
it is that happens then later on um that
allows them to say well that i know that
thing sounds harsh
but i also know i'm on board with this
movement because this is the
you know this is about civil rights this
is the next civil rights
you know thing that has to happen the
only way forward is to
you know abolish the police or you know
abandon all of history
uh what you know whatever whatever
garbagey conclusion
is has come in on the legitimate
grievances
um they're being wrapped up all nice and
tidy in some pretty paper
and some nice bows and i think what
you're saying basically is
you know this was a view behind the
curtain um this was this was a view
of what the conversation can actually
sound like um at times
with you know with people who were doing
so in
in a kind of public space it's not
exactly public because this is
invitation only and they booted a lot of
the people who they didn't want
yes and in fact the night prior to this
event
i was in a room with some of the same
people who were playing a very different
role
and the ostensible purpose of the room
the night before
was to build bridges and it was
it was i don't think especially
successful but nonetheless
the even just the ability to detect that
the same people
are playing a very different role and
revealing a very different side of
themselves in different circumstances
is you know compelling i mean you know
think about
you know naima and the difference
between the way naima came across before
evergreen started to melt down
in faculty meetings long-winded but you
know
she behaved like a colleague and then
there was a point at which it was like
oh
okay we're the enemy i guess well i do
think
that um somehow in modernity many people
assume that it is not just allowed but
expected to have multiple personas
and that you know you'll you know
certainly we're supposed to dress
differently when we go to work and we
you know have a slightly different
personality and you're supposed to make
sure that whatever you know if you're
young
you know your social media posts from
you know your party life
don't don't bleed over into your
professional life right so it's sort of
it's it's like i say not just ex not
just
okay but sort of expected that you're
gonna have these different modes of
being and
um this this was always actually really
from the beginning of us being
professors at evergreen
one of the things that struck me as
hypocritical
among our colleagues and it was hardly
limited to the faculty at evergreen
um was the was the complete
change of personality and attitude
towards students in particular that
happened as soon as
they weren't on stage as soon as the
door closes and now it's just faculty
you know the mask is off and it was it
was reprehensible
that's that was actually deplorable and
uh
i think that this you know faculty
are are really encouraged to do this to
to actually have disdain for students
and you know that's not what we're
talking about here this isn't a faculty
student relationship but i but i think
that this thing is true more widely and
everyone regardless of whether or not
they've been a teacher
or a college faculty everyone's been a
student pretty much except for those
perhaps
very few lucky of those who are who have
been unschooled
and everyone has had a bad teacher i
think you know
hopefully we've all had good teachers
too but i think everyone's had a bad
teacher and
many times what bad teacher is is
actually obscuring the fact that the
teacher has no respect for you as a
human being
sees you as a butt in a seat that has to
you know has to tick some boxes that
they can give a grade or whatever at the
end and then be done with you
and many of us can detect that
like we can detect it even if we're not
the ones who are earning their disdain
we can see the disdain directed other
people or
ourselves or whatever and boy if people
knew
what at least many college faculty
actually say
when the doors are closed i i can't
imagine
wanting to send my children into a
situation
where such people had an ability to form
an opinion at all and so
you know this the fact that you had
people one night
sounding one way and the next day
sounding a totally different way and
really a kind of an
inhuman or at least a dehumanizing way
whether or not they were behaving in a
human way they were attempting to
dehumanize others
this is appalling and i think is sort of
one of the horsemen of the existential
apocalypse that is happening
but i'm not surprised yeah i i'm
obviously not surprised either because
it's not the first time i've seen it
yeah um the you know the point you make
about professors
is so deep right and i don't
i don't understand how they even end up
there right i don't know how you stand
up and
in front of people whom you actively
disdain i don't know how you do it
right it seems like if that's your
feeling about it then
why are you there yeah get different
work yeah get different work
um but uh nonetheless it is a common
feature now i think it's interesting as
long as we're
here you and i dealt with this boundary
a little differently as professors
right from each other or yeah from each
other perfectly consistently and i would
say there was
zero lack of authenticity about you as a
professor but there was a
slight layer of increased formality
right you didn't you were not you did
not completely let your hair down
in the role of professor except with
students that you knew very very well
and and sometimes in the field yes
definitely now for me
especially on you know the farther away
the longer you're you know that's out
i would say to them in the past look
we're gonna be together for you know six
eight eleven weeks like
we're gonna be just our human cells with
one another completely right and in
in some ways the field forces that
whether you like it or not right
well i don't know actually because the
vast majority of study abroad programs
are crap
and the faculty don't engage with the
students and they're not actually
spending time with them and they're like
meeting them for two hours a day
even at a field station being like okay
now we have this assignment and now i'm
going to go back and do my faculty thing
and you do your student thing so
yeah it doesn't force it if you're not
if you're
if you're trying not to teach which most
people seem to be doing
yeah i take it back the field the way we
did the field forces it
but um but the field is not inherently
force you can go back to your cabin and
behave and think differently and just
only interact with the students a very
limited amount
but anyway in front of the class i
felt like and i think this is just an
idiosyncrasy of mine right i think
probably the way you did things where
you kept a level of formality
right but it was not inauthentic so are
you confusing formality with preparation
no no not at all okay not at all you
know that was a little bit of a dig but
i think you can understand what i what i
mean by that
no i mean look at it um that that was
there too
different questions okay um but you know
just the fact that um
you know i probably shouldn't admit this
but i you know i think i
cursed in front of the class at the same
level i do at home
right it just wasn't distinct okay but
um at home i curse more than you do
and in class i cursed less than you do
but i still cursed so
it just probably felt like it wasn't a
legitimate thing to be doing at that
level
well yeah i'm not sure i'm not sure what
it means but i sort of you know look
i think the thing is i was overcoming an
obstacle that was unique to me one that
you don't face which is
that because i was such a
uh you know lousy student is one way to
say it
um because i was such a bad match for
school um
that's that that is true and
frankly more power do you yeah yeah so
anyway in order to do the job
of being in the role of professor i had
to do it in a way that was not
inconsistent with i didn't want to be
one of those you know
do as i say not as i do you know parents
effectively so in the role of professor
i wanted to be who i was and then the
point is okay
this is a different kind of and you know
i will say
in my defense every time i taught a new
class
every time i invested very heavily in
telling people exactly what they were
getting
into i was merciless about
my flaws and how they would impact
people
and so the point was look you're signing
i'm not saying it's not worth it but
you're signing up for that right and
most people didn't believe you though
because i mean
even that this conversation for another
time
oh okay no no it just i don't we're
far-field
yes we are far-field all right so um
maybe we should uh
maybe we should cap this off here and
just say
there is something about this
environment that is allowing
things to be seen in this context
that are difficult for people to see
otherwise and that the ability to tune
into it
might be worth paying more attention to
than just the fact of some new social
media platform
uh showing up on the landscape
all right excuse me um
all right where should we go next um
there's a new paper
um called let's do this next
coronavirus disease 2019
hospitalizations
attributable to cardiometabolic
conditions in the united states
colon a comparative risk assessment
analysis that is a mouthful
but that is the title of the new paper
o'hearn at all 2021
and before um i'm just gonna
read a tiny bit from it before we talk
about it
but i will say that unlike um i i have
i've ended up dissecting a number of
papers on this podcast and that
is um what i like to do
and not not hopefully not to find
tragic flaws although a lot of the
papers we've talked about here have been
tragically flawed
but in order that we don't just take the
author's word
for what it is that they've found and so
you have to spend
actual real time with the methods and
results and still you don't have the
actual data so you can't actually redo
the analysis but you have to
in some cases like some some one of the
review papers um that was
finding asymptomatic transmission and i
thought i
revealed i think um that this was a
total crap paper and a total crap
conclusion
you could actually discern where it was
that they had generated those data
um in this this paper though um is
um really complicated
and um and there's a lot of layers that
make it
more difficult to assess it
independently so we are
basically going to stay at the level of
um
if the if the author's assessment of
what they found is true
this is what it means deductive logic
working forward from the conclusions
yeah yeah exactly so rather than the
dissection and sometimes vivisection
of papers that i i have seen you do and
participated in here on the podcast
which i have to say as much as i wish
that no papers were worthy of
vivisection i do find it um
a somewhat enjoyable task i do well you
do it well thank you
um so um i'm not uh i will have you
share my screen but not yet zach
so just in the introduction uh they say
uh in the most recent centers for
disease control and prevention analysis
of available national data among
individuals diagnosed with covet 19.
a 35 year old with diabetes mellitus
hypertension
cardiovascular disease obesity or other
chronic conditions
had a similar risk of covid19 related
hospitalization
i was a 35 year old with one of the core
mobilities as
a 75 year old with none of these
conditions
and a similar risk of covet 19 related
death as a 65 year old with none of
these conditions
a dramatic biologic aging effect of poor
metabolic health on risk of severity of
a viral infection such as covet 19.
so that is a pre-existing piece of
research from the cdc that this paper
is citing and then
i want to oh why does my
as soon as we plug the computer into
this system for the live streams
everything goes
awry okay um here is
um this is just the paper it's in the
journal of the american heart
association
o'hearn it all just published and i'm
just going to read their
set aside box here clinical perspective
what is new meaning what is new in this
paper
patients with cardiometabolic conditions
in particular obesity hypertension
diabetes mellitus and heart failure
have a high risk of poor outcomes from
coronavirus disease 2019 infection
that's actually not new we already knew
that those are some of the major
comorbidities for covered 19 for bad
outcomes
and for actually getting the disease at
all among
among more than 900 000 u.s coronavirus
disease 2019 hospitalizations
through november 18th 2020 nearly
two-thirds
63.5 percent were estimated to be
attributable
to these cardiometabolic conditions that
is preventable if these conditions had
not been present
top risks were obesity uh which is
explaining 30
of that nearly two-thirds hypertension
at 26
diabetes mellitus at 21
and then heart disease was i think about
12 or so
and then what are the clinical
implications clinicians should educate
their patients who may be at risk and
consider promoting preventative
lifestyle
measures such as improved dietary
quality and physical activity
to improve overall cardio metabolic
health and potentially minimize the risk
for coronavirus disease 2019
severity at some level
again assuming that they have done this
you know sort of like
massive data review and analysis
accurately which includes lots of places
where there are models so
lots of places for it not to have been
done brilliantly um
at some level i feel like finally
finally someone is doing this kind of
work
and talking directly about um
about actually what makes you as an
individual
more likely to have a bad outcome among
those factors that you actually
potentially have control over
you know there's been a lot of talk
about age
and it's true right the older you are
the more at risk you are of getting
and of of having a poor outcome from the
disease but you can't do anything about
that we don't we don't have the solution
to that yet
sex uh men are more likely to both get
slightly and have bad outcomes more so
um
copen19 than women and then race and
actually
um to some degree uh black people but
really
um latina what would what is often
described as hispanic people
um have um much worse
outcomes compared to their um you know
many more hispanics are affected than
you would expect from background rates
of hispanics in the population
so those are those are all true things
about which you can't do anything
right you can't just frankly you can't
just declare yourself a different age or
a different sex or a different race
right but these comorbidities
you potentially can not all of them and
not if you're really
you know really far gone but
if you start to eat better
and be more active in your life you can
reduce
your obesity and your hypertension and
potentially deal with your diabetes
mellitus
all of these are at least affected by
and in some cases
majorly affected by lifestyle choices
so i of course fully agree with that and
there is an
obvious discussion to be had about the
absurdities of this moment and the idea
that to discuss such things is to
pretend that a particular body form is
more healthy when in fact of course a
particular body form is more healthy
now i'm fat shaming right you could be
dismissed as fat shaming into the extent
that the data
seemed to reflect that this is not fat
shaming this is just analysis then we
can also complain
that data the very idea of data logic
science is white supremacist whatever it
is and so obviously
the right analysis is no none of that is
true right and it's not to say science
hasn't been put to bad ends or
bent to particular populations desires
or needs or whatever
of course it has but the point is those
tools are actually
indifferent to who you are if you use
them right and
the the thing that i want to point out
is that
there's a whole set of analyses that one
wants
in effect there are going to be dozens
of factors
involved in how likely you are to
contract cover 19
and what happens to you after you do
right type o blood
appears to be involved it seems to be
somewhat protective as compared to type
a
so we talked about that in like our
first or second live stream and i
haven't seen anything
about that for many months now have you
seen anything else yes i did to see
something recent but i don't have it
uh maybe but that seems to be holding
seems to behold okay
um but here's here's the point type o
blood
is not going to be independent of all
these other factors so
does the fact that uh black people and
hispanic people are facing
more covid does that hold if we control
for vitamin d
probably because the comparison between
blacks and hispanics
likely involves blacks making less
vitamin d as a result of just
being on average darker or if we control
for obesity and hypertension rates
right and so that's what you really want
to do is figure out how many of these
things are correlated
indirectly through something else right
through through
cultural factors right how many people
live in a household can have effects
um uh you know it could be genetic
factors but indirect
like melanin production and its
interface with vitamin d production
one of the things we talked about
earlier a paper you brought to the
discussion was
um the the local subway lines that
people were forced to take
more people were more likely to be
forced to take to get to work if they
lived in low-income
areas in new york city this was a new
york city-based subway now right which
was a beautiful case
of something that had nothing to do
inherently with biology but was having
impacts on biology by virtue of the way
the city is constructed right
um the neighborhoods in the city were
effectively
segregated by ethnicity and so people of
certain ethnicities were at more risk of
getting the thing
because they happen to live in places
and we're taking these subway
lines where they were stuck in these
tiny cars with lots of people getting on
and off all the time
so um anyway one wants the analysis of
variance that picks apart all of the
factors figures out which ones are
actually directly correlated and which
ones evaporate
when you control for their connection to
other things
and then you would be maximally armed
and so in some sense we all carry around
this you know
this stuff from the beginning which is
very probably true
in fact it's hard to imagine how it's
false that age
is this dominant factor but the point is
okay
if in effect obesity causes you to
behave like somebody who's much older
right with respect to contracting covet
19 then the point is well you don't have
control over the age
but you might have control over the
obesity right and so
thinking in these terms like okay we all
probably have a few
tick marks against us with respect to
covet 19 and then we have some other
places
where you know we may have uh the
opportunity to do something and the
question is well how low can you get
your risk and you know if you can't get
your risk metabolically low
maybe you need to correct for it
behaviorally right
so the point is armed with information
you are in the best position
to manage this which also means stopping
the focus
on death which is of course you know
death is very important but
from the point of view of actually you
may get over this thing but it may rob
you of a decade of life by virtue of
what it's done to your lungs or your
circulatory tissue
that's a very important factor and um
anyway
the only right answer here is for us to
figure out how to do these analyses so
they're not polluted
so that our information and therefore
our models both formal and informal get
better over time which then arms us
maximally to protect ourselves and to
you know
to to uh to choose our future you know
collectively like
at what point do we um you know say well
this is under control
enough that we have to prioritize
the world moving forward right that's a
discussion we can only have if we have
really good information
on where we are and what our actual
risks are yes no that's right
and um you know unfortunately all of the
new variants are making that
conversation even harder to have
um because oh you know we
we might have expected in fact i think
we predicted early on
um that um this was you know
this this is likely to become less very
land over time it's effectively
i and i and i have seen a number of
other scientists propose this is likely
to become just a circulating background
disease that
effectively children get exposed to
and thus have some immunity to going
forward
um i don't know and i've seen no one
attempt an analysis
of what these different variants
that are wildly different in terms of
both transmissibility
and death rate might do to that analysis
right
or even like how we proceed with
analysis in the light of those really
and you know i mean we've got two novel
factors here
one the ultimate wild card if this isn't
a natural virus if this is a modified
virus
then it will not abide by our
expectations uh evolutionarily that are
based on
what wild viruses do when they jump now
it's also
quite possible that it would be novel in
its own right having jumped from nature
with
no human tinkering maybe this is just
going to follow a different pattern and
we're going to learn something about
viruses we didn't know
but if it's modified if it is enhanced
then one expects a very um different
pattern to
emerge from this the other thing is that
these vaccines
are it is increasingly clear to me that
these vaccines
are novel not only with respect to the
frightening
interaction that they have with systems
where we can't predict what the
long-term impact is going to be because
we haven't seen it yet and
you're talking specifically about the
mrna vaccines or also about the dna
vaccine so just to
so and we've talked a lot about vaccines
on the show before but we've got
pfizer and moderna uh faizo and pfizer
and bioentec
and modern vaccines those two which are
widespread in the u.s at this point
which are both mrna vaccines
and you've got the astrazeneca oxford
vaccine which it looks like
is not going to be available in the us
but is available a few other places and
johnson
johnson which may be about to get fda
approval in the u.s
both of those astrazeneca and johnson
and johnson are dna vaccines
also not traditional but they use a
delivery mechanism of an adenovirus
rather than these lipid nanoparticles
yep and i
see in you know various comments that we
get uh in various places we're having
trouble conveying
uh the evolutionary uh approach
here so to the extent that the
astrazeneca and johnson and johnson
vaccines
are not um a tried and true
technology they're somewhat more tried
and true than the lipid nanoparticles
that are used for the mrna vectors one
part of them is tried and true
right one part of them is more
traditional vaccine-wise but what it
also
is is something that we have
evolutionary experience with that has
nothing to do with vaccines that is to
say
experience with adenoviruses right so
that experience with adenoviruses that
our ancestors and
probably each of us has had actually
makes this safer
as well um but in any case
the so when i'm talking about the novel
factor of the vaccines i'm actually
talking about so we've really got two
categories we've got the mrna vaccines
and their lipid nanoparticles
and the adenovirus vaccines dna vaccines
and their adenoviruses just to be very
careful about mrna with lipid
nanoparticles dna
with adenovirus so the adenovirus
vaccines are carrying their information
in the form of dna
which then gets translated into rna
which then creates spike protein which
then alerts the immune system exactly as
the
mrna vaccines do but
there is another unique factor here
which has nothing to do with the
delivery mechanism
at all in which in both in all four
of these vaccines the two different
categories
for vaccines and that is that we are
very narrowly targeting the spike
protein and by very narrowly targeting
the spike protein we are creating
a uh an evolutionary a concentrated
evolutionary force
whereas cruder more primitive vaccine
technologies
that you know take a a whole virus
and either break it up or neutralize its
pathogenic effect
those things are much more general and
so
the compare so be more precise about
that but when you say they're much more
general
you're basically you're giving your body
and attenuated
or you know pieces of the original virus
and your body can then develop
an ability to recognize lots of
different parts of that
whereas the four vaccines that we named
the two mrna and the two dna vaccines
only provide the body with an ability to
recognize the spike protein
which means that if the spike protein is
to change just to
list one possible problem with this if
the spike protein is to evolve
then all the all of these four vaccines
are rendered useless not useless
uh less useful less useful but it does
two things i mean
this is the thing we're in if this
weren't so politicized this would be
incredibly fascinating so politicized
and so dangerous
this would be fascinating because what
we're doing is experimenting with a much
more
targeted vaccine right narrowly targeted
that narrowly targeted vaccine increases
the likelihood of
our vaccines becoming more useless
over time because we're creating a very
precise
attack that the virus will be favored to
resist
however it also creates the possibility
of effectively swapping out the
information in these
vaccines without going through the rest
of it which is part of
why at least i mean i i know much less
about the dna vaccine development but
the mrna vaccine development
has the potential to be so fast and
indeed apparently one of them i don't
remember which was actually
created in a weekend back in like
february or march of last year
and you know if they turn out to be as
safe and effective as the whole world is
hoping that they are
then this really does mean that future
pandemics could be halted pretty quickly
with you know widespread inoculation by
uh
new you know rapidly developed mrna
vaccines potentially
now what you really want to know is how
much of the variance
in the risk that comes with these things
is due
to the delivery mechanism and how much
is due to the
uh the informational content whether
it's in mrna or dna
because if the danger is
in the informational content then you
can't
uh make the safety process rep more
rapid
right you have to go through it on the
other hand right
if the danger is really in the delivery
mechanism then a
maybe we can refine that right we can
reduce the danger and still get the
delivery
and then b swap out the information
and you could even imagine a future not
so far down the road
where you might not have to have
centralized creation of these things you
could have you know effectively like
printing newspapers
in each town right you could have a
factory 3d printing for vaccines
the equivalent right you could have that
sort of thing taking place so that as
the thing as we got really good at
tracking
uh pathogens and epidemics we would also
get really good at delivering
you know it could be targeted in the
sense that your
vaccine could be built for the
particular strains that are circulating
in your municipality
um so anyway there's lots of
possibilities here um
but boy what a dangerous experiment
we're discovering this stuff
in india indeed
uh anything else there no all right
um we move on to sexism and science i
thought we were gonna go to
the um the vaccination of
children uh i don't i didn't
follow through on that so i i have some
links but i don't i didn't
spend any time with the research um so
can you put up the
the paper yeah well
i don't think you have it zach um i have
i
this isn't an original paper this is
just a report yeah this is a science
news
article published this week so in
science vaccine trials ramp up in
children adolescents
and let's see there's um there's a quote
here
if memory serves here we go um adult
deaths from covet 19 dwarf those in
children
in the united states for example young
people make up about 250 of 500 000
total deaths
but for children coven 19 is still quote
causing more deaths than influence it
does in a typical season
says douglas dickema a pediatrician and
bioethicist at seattle children's
hospital
quote those are unnecessary deaths and
should be prevented
so i i found this uh report a bit
upsetting
um not only so first of all to say
it still causes more deaths than
influenza in a given year
a turns out to be questionable so i've
got that
link here yeah you want to show that um
so again i just
i did not spend any time here so i just
i went and looked at
the cdc on influenza and um this
is oh boy uh so
in the 2019-2020 influenza season
there were 188 reported pediatric flu
deaths
and that was a fairly high year
apparently but you scroll down
and you find that
um again you like i was not ready for
this
um oh here we go well any death in a
child from a vaccine preventable illness
is a tragedy
the number of pediatric flu deaths
reported to cdc each season is
likely an undercount for example even
though the reported number of deaths
during the 2017-18 flu season was 188
cdc estimates that turns out to be the
same number i think this year
cdc estimates the actual number was
closer to 600.
it is likely the actual number of
children who died from flu during the
2019-2020 season is higher as well
and i would say this is you know based
on no data
but that given the ways that kova deaths
have been counted
that i think if there is an error in
attributing
deaths to covet and children it's the
other way
it's an over count and the cdc is
telling us that they think that deaths
attributable to flu in children
is reliably an undercount and if those
two even if those things aren't true
those two numbers of deaths so far from
covet and deaths this last year from
uh flu and children are so close that
you would at least need to do a
statistical analysis
and um you know this this claim from
this pediatrician and bioethicist
um that it's it's higher higher deaths
in covid
in children from covert than from flu is
suspect at best and the idea that we are
making policy based on this
policy which involves vaccinating
children
is scary yeah not only making policy
um but doing so in
um in a way that has hidden hazards that
aren't discussed here
so actually zach would you put up the
graph that i sent you
so this is also um cdc in origin this is
2019
2018 2019 and you can see there
that the number of flu deaths in
zero to four is at two
can you read it yeah it's 250 266 2016.
but then 5 to 17 is 211.
so i don't know you know i don't know
what the children demarcation is for
covid but um certainly it's over four
right now so that's that's a bigger
number than
we were seeing right now go back to the
uh the
report the science news article yeah the
science news article
okay now unfortunately do you want sac
to show this yeah you can show it and
scroll up unfortunately
i can't see it there but i believe
that the numbers here
so i saw was it here
this is embarrassing but they had a
deaths
in the 0 to 20 range and by saying
zero to zero to 20 years old years old
exactly
um i can't find it there but it creates
a bias because effectively what we've
got is
evidence that very young children are
pretty well protected and that the
numbers are very low
what they're not saying here and what
troubles me
is that okay first of all it's
manipulative
to say any these deaths are preventable
and any is too many right
coming out against the death of children
is you know
not uh it is a position that everybody
will
embrace and many will strongly do so on
an emotional basis no but it it at best
pretends and at worst
no it best doesn't understand and at
worst pretends that tradeoffs don't
exist
right exactly and so there is reason to
keep
children away from these vaccines that
comes from the fact that they
by virtue of their age are very well
protected
from catching and treat and apparently
transmitting and transmitting
and suffering bad outcomes right and
they've got the most of their lives to
live to experience what we hope are no
but might be long-term side effects of
these new vaccines
that's exactly it not only do they have
more of their lives ahead of them in
which bad outcomes could emerge imagine
outcomes that are delayed 30 or 40 years
right
if you're 50 and you get a vaccine that
has a
delayed bad outcome right you may not
live to experience it or it
may not compromise much of your life but
if you're young of course
um it will but um
but the other thing is developmental
right the question is what is the age at
which it is most reasonable to start
vaccinating
right now you and i in dealing with
vaccinations for our children
and we did fully vaccinate them but we
had a rubric which was to delay
each of the vaccinations as long as
possible so that we would get the full
protection of those vaccines there was
no point in vaccinating
kids against things that they weren't
going to encounter so we vaccinated them
at the point that
an encounter with the pathogen was
likely and we delayed we delayed travel
you know the reason
part of the reason that i was doing
study abroad alone for many years
when i was just driven to do it and i
wanted you to be part of it and our
children to be part of it
and you know you really pushed back
against it and said there you know yes
lots of people live in these places but
you know we're we're not going to put
our children in the situation where we
have to choose between exposing them to
diseases
and vaccinating them earlier than um
than we think they should be vaccinated
so we didn't take them for instance to
you know
the ecuador and amazon until we felt
they were old enough to get the full
you know yellow fever and all the rest
of the vaccinations that they really we
felt they needed to have in order to be
safe there
right so okay we're gonna vaccinate kids
who are better protected are more are
going to have
likely to have greater impacts both
because of the amount of time
and because of the early stage in their
development at which they're
encountering these vaccines which open
up possibilities
for bad outcomes that adults won't have
and at the same time in that article it
describes the fact that because we have
pretty good data
from the uh the safety trials that have
already been done these trials are being
scaled back in terms of the number
right so basically this is being treated
as pro forma which is exactly the
opposite of a
responsible uh approach to this the
responsible approach would say
kids have less to gain and more to lose
we should be
very sure about the safety and then we
should figure out what the age is rather
than clumping people
0 to 20. that's correct right which is
crazy because you know
kids 18 19 do have some substantial risk
so anyway the the elephant in the room
of course
is the perverse incentive surrounding
the profitability of vaccinating
everybody
and so i increasingly think we have to
worry about what role that is playing
yeah it does not make sense to me maybe
somebody will explain to us
why uh why we don't get it but it
doesn't make sense to me that all of the
people who definitely had covid
and i understand there's a problem with
people who may have had covet right but
people who definitely had kovid they've
had the equivalent of a vaccine
and it's not obvious that this couldn't
compromise immunity in ways that we
discussed last time
or at the very least be needless and
expose them to risks that we can't
say much about because they could be
very well delayed and we haven't seen
the outcomes here so
at the level of a desire to vaccinate
everyone as if vaccination is inherently
good and the more people we can get it
to the better
that does not uh pay proper heed to the
fact that the cost benefit analysis is
very different
depending upon who you are and that
means we should be
hedging out those risks for several
different groups of people
exactly and those yeah the the three
populations that i've mentioned multiple
times are you you've already mentioned
two of them it's children
it's people who've already had covet and
it's pregnant women
yep absolutely yeah all right now can we
talk about sexism
yes awesome all right okay so
um this i just ran across this
remarkably sexist obituary of a female
chemist
the right response is you okay just
please just don't
no go ahead i just don't want you giving
something away here because of the way
i'm
i'm not i was gonna give you permission
to talk about sexism
oh thank you sir thank you
you're welcome wow okay uh so this
really sexist obituary of a female
chemist
came to my attention this week and um
before i read just a bit of it to share
just you know how obnoxious it is um let
me say a few things about what
what her contributions were because they
don't show up in this o bed at all
um she made contributions in electric
arc lighting and sediment transport
she run the she won the royal society's
illustrious hadley medal
and she held 26 patents so this is you
know this is no slouch
in in science land but this excerpt
written by
one um henry e armstrong
includes so this this obituary includes
the following two paragraphs
mrs eriton was one of those who aspired
to prove that woman can be as man as an
original scientific inquirer
did she succeed if we are to frame a
psychology of the scientific mind
regarding this as a species apart
we must carefully note and analyze the
doings of such as she
i have but small qualification for the
office yet as she was my colleague's
wife
and we often met and were in fair
sympathy i was able to take notice of
her idiosyncrasies and of the conditions
under which she was placed
and another paragraph uh a few
a few a few paragraphs later my god um
speaking as he does
as this obituary writer does throughout
the entire thing really speaking of the
husband who was also a scientist and
she's just like the
the hanger on um says
so this is the obituary writer and the
hymn here is the husband
not the person the obituary is about i
often told him
that he and his wife are an ill-asserted
couple being both enthusiastic and
having cognate interests they constantly
worried each other about the work they
were doing
he should have had a humdrum wife an
active useful sort of person such as
lady catherine recommended mr collins to
marry
who would have put him into carpet
slippers when he came home fed him well
and led him not to worry either himself
or other people especially other people
then he would have lived a longer and a
happier life and done far more effective
work i believe
my god right like just just incredible
right
so the pro the problem is that because
she was scientifically productive
she could not properly tend to him which
made him less productive
yes the the obituary author believes
that the man who i don't even know if
he's dead or not
like would have been a even more
impressive scientist if he had simply
had
a uh a humdrum wife an active useful
sort of person
yes so this in the obituary of the woman
right
okay so there's been a call to retract
this sexist obituary right
here's an excerpt from the call to
retract and as i said i didn't read the
whole obituary but it didn't include
any of the you know and that's just a
few of her remarkable achievements the
call to retract includes its brazen
sexism serves only as a monument to how
long and hard women have had to fight
for an equal place at the scientific
table and it's anti-semitic
this meaning this mean anti-eulogy is by
someone who knew little of irritant or
her work
the chemist henry armstrong airs doubts
about whether women could be scientists
and cast aspersions on airten's
originality and intelligence by striking
contrast other obituaries such as that
in the guardian
celebrate her remarkable scientific
achievement after a letter of complaint
armstrong with breathtaking arrogance
chatted his critic for
lacking a sense of humor and requested
one correction to a typographical error
so um these are these are some good
points right this is a terrible
uh a really terrible obituary and it's
sexist it's awful it frames the
scientists career entirely in terms of
what her husband was and
how if she had been less interesting her
husband could have been more so maybe
um but you know in general calls to
retract her antithetical to science
journals on the other hand an obituary
isn't a science paper
but there is one other salient point in
this story
that um that i think is worth pointing
out which is that
the call to retraction was published
last week in 2021
and the obituary was published in 1923
98 years ago so
truly stunning really that we have a
call to retraction for a 98 year old
obituary
which if if it happened
it disappears history like it's actually
important to know
that accomplished scientists from 98
years ago
were being written about in this way we
need to know these things
well i'm actually for the retraction oh
if it would bring her back i was unable
to find any information on whether that
would be the consequence yeah but
but wouldn't we need to bring her
husband back too he probably is dead by
now and given that you know she was best
with him
she we would need him back as well all
right
i hadn't thought about that dimension i
i admit it's uh always ringing the
husband
yes always forgetting the husband but
yeah you know
look my sense exactly is your sense
is that it is absolutely essential that
we not retract this
right 100 right i mean
precisely because it teaches exactly the
right lesson it's just so obvious
well like it's it's adorable
right yes chemist henry armstrong proves
how adorable he is right
well but i mean how provincial and
absurd and how
you know how different a world we live
in i mean
you remember the uh the elders in the
museum
where we learned our craft right yeah
spoke
of many things one of them was a
generation
prior the concern that women couldn't do
field biology because where would they
pee right
i don't actually remember you don't
remember this well that was
a story that you know dick liked to tell
right and you know think alexander dick
alexander
my phd advisor who mentored many many
women he didn't he wasn't
ever fooled by this kind of nonsense but
the idea he was not sexist in any way
right
so in any case how important
is it for you know modern women in
science to be able to go back and say oh
well on the one hand 1923 is a while ago
and on the other hand it's not that long
right and look how far we've moved right
that is that is significant and so it
just goes to the whole
instinct to tear down the monuments
right to some era to pretend right
that it didn't happen somehow as if it's
not going to make the problem
worse like bring back sexism and you
know it is it is
actually is a kin this like a
historicity which
also i think uh obscures a little bit of
an innumeracy
uh in which that thing that happened in
the past
is now imagined to be what is happening
right now and you know the person who's
um advocating for the retraction doesn't
pretend that this didn't happen 98 years
ago but she still says we should retract
it
um and in fact i don't i don't have the
whole thing right here but
um it reminded me a little bit of you
know again to go full circle here
the claims when evergreen was blowing up
that what was happening on this college
campus this you know the most
progressive college campus
in the u.s maybe in which literally
no founded claims of racism ever came to
the fore
we were being compared to alabama in the
1950s
like literally that was the claim on
stage by various people before the blow
up and during the blow blowup and like
you know this this felix this is insane
yes by
staff at the college who were supposed
to be bringing us together and creating
an educational environment and of course
he was doing exactly the opposite on
both fronts
so you know i'm i am grateful to the
person who was called to retract this
obituary because i got to go
back and read this obituary and thought
wow i didn't so i didn't know
that a woman who died in 1923
would have you know would have been
doing all of that work
right like you know we all have sort of
marie curie as like the example
of a female scientist from early on and
actually you know like
the great women of mathematics account
on twitter um
is um also celebrate some of the
the older um the historic figures from
mathematics
but um to have had this person be so
actually accomplished and then so
denigrated in death
is really useful to know like i'm glad i
know that even though i find this
modern letter to nature absurd and part
indicative of exactly the problem we've
been talking about
there's a kind of defective
thinking that i i'm i'm sure it isn't
local
to the left always but i'm seeing it
very
in a very concentrated form on
especially the extreme
uh left the woke left which has to do
with a sense of um
because we look back at history and we
recognize certain things
as clearly absurd and wrong there is a
desire which i think is totally
legitimate to be on the right side of
history and i
i'm one of these people who disagrees
people are always complaining about
those who say
be on the right side of history or this
is the right side of history or whatever
the claim is the problem is you never
actually know for sure
um but the idea that that's where you're
supposed to be
right you're supposed to understand how
history will judge you know this or that
and being on the right side of history
is a laudable goal
but because of that there is this
uh manipulable nature to people
who understand that to be the objective
where the point is
you can paint this as that and then the
person will jump
because the point is well the last thing
they want to be is discovered to be on
the wrong side of history and so
i see this unfolding in and around
the issue of trans where i tweeted this
week that
you didn't actually need to
surrender the sexual binary which we've
pointed out so many times goes back
500 million years in in our lineage um
nor do you need to at least at least nor
do you need to invent any new
pronouns or force people to say they
them
the fact is you can fully honor and
protect
trans people by just allowing them to
choose whether they want he he or she
right
and so in any case the point is that the
desire to portray these modifications of
language
as the right side of history right and
then we can look back at
you know what happened with
homosexuality right
and so people then immediately jump to
i'll do whatever it is so that i'm not
you know i'm not the villain in this
case causes them to embrace things which
actually don't naturally follow
right and my point about the pronouns
for example
would be that look i'm perfectly
persuaded that there are trans people
and that the right thing to do
is uh to honor whatever their choice of
pronouns is
among the two normal choices it becomes
though an exercise of power
at the point that you say ah you're
going to call me sir
right it does and um
sorry go on well anyway my only point is
that um the the ability
of people to be manipulated on the basis
of a strong desire not to be caught out
by history is tied up
in the same thing where where instead of
leaving
this absurd obituary as a monument or
leaving
you know the statue of a great president
who is compromised by his having held
slaves
right leaving that to you know spark
the proper curiosity of people in the
future how
how maybe they're teaching moments right
like
remember how education was you know and
when i first heard this phrase i thought
oh my goodness that's ridiculous but
you know like you you use the surprising
the offensive
the unusual as a teaching moment now
let's figure out what it means
let's let's go forward from here right
and and
you know the contradiction right george
washington
could have been king he refused it
out of moral decency yeah and yet he
held slaves
so the point is all right that sounds
like a human story and it sounds like
one that one doesn't want
to shortchange by turning it into a
cartoon and you know
by pretending well of course he's so
compromised by his flaws
that we can no longer even pay attention
to his accomplishments
you know or his decency that um you know
it builds a totally phony history yeah
so just to get back to
pronouns for a moment as as you know one
of the essays that i'm
sort of working on in the background has
to do a lot with with pronouns and what
it
what kind of a power play it is but um
you know the thing the thing that's
absent from your just thumbnail analysis
there
is the moving target and you know it
didn't
we're no longer even just talking about
trans
we're now talking about non-binary and
you know non-binary
has no place in this discussion at all
it's just it's a total fabrication
right and um you know you present how
you want but
you know the pronouns refer to your sex
and um
and if you you know really feel that you
need to be referred to
as the sex that you were not born to
then all of us who are interested in
respecting you are going to do that but
um the creation of new pronouns is a
perfect match for
the invocation of 93 000 genders and you
know like
and all of this other ridiculousness um
that um that just
just departs entirely from reality it's
just not pretending anymore really
um and it's it's it some people i'm sure
are actually enjoying
watching the good-hearted trying to
play ball and you know get on board the
next civil rights thing
um liberals um like us but you know the
the confused um they're like okay i'll
i'll i guess i'll call you that thing
i guess i'm not sure what that is for
anyway and
like can we can what
why can we not agree universally
on some of the things that until
yesterday to use douglas murray's
formulation
everyone knew right okay
you have caused me to formulate exactly
what uh
what i'm seeing that that's troubling me
which is
the recognition that there is something
that must be done
and the false connection with
past examples causes people to trip over
themselves to
try to get out in front of the race to
be
you know to be decent to
some oppressed group and the problem is
that the desire hey
whatever it is that needs to be done to
uh
to honor trans people i want to be in
front of it right i want to be in the
lead
that desire to be in the lead is what
causes people to say oh i know what we
can do
right and it allows bad actors to tack
on
these uh things that amount to power and
um that is where the whole thing falls
apart and so you know
now why why does the discussion about
trans require us
to pretend anything at all about the
sexual binary right
it's trans it actually is built from the
sexual binary
right it depends on that it depends on
if trans is real uh then the sexual
binary is real and the sexual binary is
real and interestingly my tweet
garnered at least three responses i know
of
from people who are
famously trans who were who agreed
sure yep
all right good segue to octopus of
course okay this is this is just brief
um but um here we have a
science news article and i can link to
the full article too but it's pretty
it's pretty dense
um no actually this is editor's choice
so each week the editors at science go
and look at papers that are published
elsewhere and uh
and talk about what they think um the
readers of science might be interested
in
uh and so this tiny little blurb
uh says among other things cats
at all the authors of the original
research published in the journal of
experimental biology
found that octopus arms display a photo
tactic response to light
automatically withdrawing when the arm
especially the tip is illuminated
so this is akin to mammals or
if you're not familiar with other
mammals the human response when you
reach towards a hot stove and retract it
that this is you know this this is
actually a spinal cord reflux this isn't
even going through the
the brain i think that reflex um and you
know obviously
um cephalopods aren't vertebrates we
don't they don't have a central nervous
system that's evolved in the same way
ours is but
um this this phototaxis in
the tips without any um
without connection to the brain is
incredible to me
yeah it's just incredible it's
fascinating now i did go back to the
original
paper and it said something that caught
me totally off guard which i couldn't
track down the reasoning but it
basically assumed
that um that uh that octopi
have poor proprioception yes it does
doesn't it yeah i don't know
why it would assume that but nonetheless
this was yeah no it's
it's it's built into the assumption yeah
i've got the paper here
i don't it does assume that it's also
it they also only started out with four
octopi and then one
died um during the experiment so they
ended up with three
um so you know it's a tiny sample size
yeah as you would expect like as you
would really hope for
with uh you know a lab lab experiment on
such intelligent creatures that they're
not
using you know hundreds of animals but
yeah i don't know if you saw in the
footnotes that two of them actually
escaped and they caught up to them at a
bar across town yeah yeah yeah
yep um but anyway yeah this is really
interesting and i think it um
actually it's weird eric and i were
having a conversation about octopi
uh yesterday um yes you mentioned his
insistence on a non-standard plural oh
yes i did mention that didn't i
um in any case the uh there is a
question
about why octopi are so unusual
and have so many features that we regard
as emblematic of intelligence and
maybe consciousness without being social
a topic i would like to return to later
i think there's a lot to be said
uh on this topic and this uh little bit
may
begin to tell us something about it the
the um
well the paper did say that they
believed that the animal had the ability
to override
the response unlike the touching of a
hot
stove yeah um which it would almost have
to be given what what occupy are capable
of doing with respect to moving their
limbs and obviously they do go out in
the light and so if that was like
touching a hot
stove they wouldn't do it yeah yeah
all right um yes sir i was looking at
this abstract it's it's it's a strange
paper
interesting result yeah yeah definitely
um
i think that's it all right we've
arrived we've arrived we have uh some
announcements
and uh then then we're done for the week
all right for february um we're gonna
take a 15-minute break
hey uh in about 15 minutes answering
questions from the super chat that you
posed this hour and the ones you pose
next hour
um once again the dark horse membership
private q a is happening tomorrow at 11
a.m pacific for two hours the questions
have already been asked for that
um but if you join at my patreon uh
you will at the five dollar up level you
will have access to that and we leave it
we leave it up as well so even if you
can't join live
um you will be able to see it although
the numbers are small enough that we
actually
uh view the chat while we're doing it
and are able to interact some
and it's it's it's fun we're enjoying it
a lot yeah
um you you can also join brad at his
patreon
where you're going to be having cool
conversations next weekend actually the
first one next saturday will be before
our next
um our next live stream that's true
it's going to be nine o'clock pacific
that way that'll give me a little
breathing room afterwards so i will just
kind of scratch that on your patreon
i've got to switch that on the
announcement yep
um you we we need to get out some new
merchandise uh and a while ago you
indicated that we might be interested in
hiring an
artist and um applications poured
in to our um our moderator a
darkhorse.moderator gmail.com
and we have we have now and so our
moderator
um basically put together powerpoints
for us and so we couldn't see anything
about who or where
or what or cost or anything and just um
showed us all of this art and we have
now
selected some finalists and that's not
to say there weren't amazing artists
among
among
they were quite annoying so many amazing
ones and um
also many different types of of art such
that for different types of projects we
might reach out to some of the people
who
who contacted us who haven't yet been
but all the finalists have been
contacted at this point
um and you can also you so you don't
need to send more art to
darkhorse.moderator gmail.com but if you
have questions
um you know i've actually begun seeing
um questions to me directly oh
i heard you had a p.o box where can i
send a letter so you can
get that information from
darkhorse.miter gmail.com
maybe that's it maybe that's it maybe
that's it all right we will see you
in 15 minutes and for those of you
listening on audio we'll catch you next
week
and in the next 15 minutes we encourage
you to eat good food and go outside
go outside um also what we didn't
mention
is the tristan harris oh yes dark horse
podcast
is up um anyway it's great conversation
i think you will really enjoy it but
check that out
yeah i'm looking forward to listening to
it all right be well everybody
[Music]
[Music]
you